bonsoir j'en avais merci d'être avec
nous donc vote au sénat et à l'assemblée
aujourd'hui beaucoup ont crié à la
mascarade le fn votre parti vos
collègues en tout cas ont voté contre
pour la plupart pour quelles raisons
selon vous votez contre m'écouter parce
que tout simplement ce ton d'abord
triomphaliste utilisé par le
gouvernement a pas monsieur castex est
insupportable ce manque d'humilité ce
manque d'écouté ce manque de démocratie
devienne insupportable
en effet et nous sommes aussi ciation
aujourd'hui qui est la conséquence d'un
fiasco vaccinale dont mails macron dont
le gouvernement sont totalement
responsables avec l'union européenne
nous vivons une situation qui est la
conséquence d'un gouvernement qui a
manqué d'ambition qui l'a jamais kovacs
1 qui a moqué qui a raillé
donald trump lorsque rappelez-vous le
lui-même avait dit avant noël 2020 il y
aura un vaccin qui sera produit inventé
aux états unis tout le monde l'avait
raillé
il avait raison ce gouvernement n'a
aucune ambition aucun esprit
d'anticipation sur le lit des
réanimations encore hier soir dans son
exercice de communication et même la
crau nous promettez ce qui nous avait
promis à un an c'est-à-dire des lits
supplémentaires en réanimation
on en a toujours pas je crois que ce
gouvernement se fout de nous et puis il
est moins on va continuer à penser que
cette interview et et vos critiques mais
tout de même le fn qui votent contre
pourquoi ne pas s'abstenir parce qu'on
est bien obligé aujourd'hui de toutes
façons de faire quelque chose est-ce que
c'était la bonne solution de le voter
contre ça sert à quoi
oui mais vous savez parce que d'abord le
gouvernement depuis un an a décidé de
tout décider tout seul
il a donc décidé de tout décider de
prendre les plus mauvaises décisions à
prendre et ils bloquent la démocratie
barak tout simplement
cet état d'urgence qu'il a décidé de
mettre en place et l'établir et leur
action nationale a décidé d'engager en
de s'opposer à cette posture là qui
n'est pas normal
nous avons des propositions à faire nous
avons des propositions à faire
rappelez-vous sur la gestion par exemple
des frontières lorsque nous demandions
il y a en février les nanas par la voix
de marine le pen
l'arrêt
lula sur les frontières nous avons
jamais été écouté le gouvernement douze
mois plus tard a fini par nous écouter
quand nous disions nous avions un
problème en effet de capacité de lire
une réanimation et qu'il fallait mais
développer l'union européenne a mis la
pression sur le budget de la santé en
france et le gouvernement nous a pas
écoutés sur les vaccins
quel problème quel est le problème
aujourd'hui devant lequel nous nous
trouvons nous avons une pénurie de
vaccins
parce que l'union européenne a très mal
négocié parce que nous avons dédié à des
incompétents
cette négociation de vaccins ceci n'est
pas acceptable
plutôt que d'être dans la recherche de
solutions j'écoutais dans vos droits au
pantages madame jean castex qui disait
si vous m'aviez proposé formuler des
recommandations je les aurai adopté eh
bien écoutez le front national lors
assemblée nationale en a formulé une il
y à un vaccin en russie qui s'appelle
boutique de pied à disposition qui a été
acheté en inde qui étaient achetés en
afrique que les hongrois même les
allemands souhaitent maintenant acheter
parce qu'ils en ont marre de cette union
européenne dans laquelle nous sommes
piégés
eh bien écoutez les français pour des
principes pour des principes d'orgueil
de fierté et d'idéologie ont décidé de
ne pas de ne pas y avoir recours
c'est compliqué nous avons un
gouvernement qui a choisi une europe qui
ne protège pas il aurait pu proches il
aurait pu choisir plutôt une france qui
protège
sur ce point là d'ailleurs vous êtes
d'accord avec jean luc mélenchon qui a
dit exactement la même chose ce matin
spoutnik vais utiliser pour ne pas
justement pas utilisé pour des raisons
idéologiques alors je vous propose
d'écouter la réponse d'un homme que vous
connaissez certainement dans les
couloirs des commissions de secrétaire
d'état chargé des affaires européennes
clément bonne écoute et sur la stricte
mais justement il s'agit pas d'exclure
par principe politique par ce serait une
erreur une faute sanitaires et
politiques de dire le vaccin russe ne
voudront pas parce qu'ils les russes le
vaccin russe il doit faire comme tout le
monde c'est à dire déposé son dossier
s'il estime être suffisamment efficace à
l'agencé européenne du médicament nous
en remettons à cet avis commun européen
c'est ce qui se passe il a déposé
tardivement son dossier mais ne l'a fait
il a une première étape d'examen qu'on
appelle une revue scientifique qui sans
doute pas
moi même en charge évidemment et
scientifique mais qui sans doute nous
dit-on s'écoulera au moins jusqu'à la mi
juin et ensuite il ya une dernière étape
qui est l'autorisent l'avis de l'agencé
européenne du médicament sur
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché qui
prend encore quelques semaines donc ça
n'est pas un vaccin qui est autorise à
bhl vraisemblablement avant la fin du
mois de juin et je les dis il faut deux
critères simples pour qu'un vaccin soit
injecté dans les bras des français
qu'ils soient validées scientifiquement
c'est évidemment la moindre des choses
avec la même méthodologie pour tous les
vaccins
quelle que soit leur nationalité et qui
se produit or aujourd'hui on en sait
c'est qu'il est faible vent produits
peut-être que ça changera à l'été mais
il est faiblement produits il n'y a pas
une production massive de vaccins russe
que nous nous priverons ça n'est pas le
cas donc pas avant la fin juin j'ai
entendu un cédant 3 mois apparemment la
faute aux russes qui n'ont pas déposé
assez vite qui fournissent pas c'est bon
qu'il fournisse au passage d'autres pays
quand même je crois 57 pays dans le
monde vous répondez quoi vous connaissez
les méandres de la procédure européenne
pourquoi elles sont si l'on sait si en
tout ce qui vient d'être ce qui vient
d'être formulée parce que les russes
nous ont mis à disposition la licence au
pouvoir produire
l'italie met à disposition des outils de
production pour pouvoir produire le
vaccin spoutnik
l'allemagne est prête à le faire nous
avons nous des sites de production le
problème c'est que nous aurons pas de
vaccin à produire mais nous pourrions le
faire pour des raisons purement
idéologiques purement idéologiques il ya
ce point de blocage et on nous renvoie
au mois de juin alors que ça fait déjà
deux mois que l'âme le proc' la
procédure d'homologation est entamée
c'est honteux honteux tout ceci on a
bien compris que derrière il ya un vrai
problème puisque et aux politiques
qu'ils apprennent de blocage idéologique
moi je crois que quand on est président
de la république quand on doit protéger
son peuple
eh bien on doit utiliser tous les
recours possibles pour voir le protéger
la france ne le fait pas et même mac on
ne le fait pas le gouvernement non plus
si honteux nous sommes aujourd'hui vous
savez vous expliquer cette de la
crispation de la france quand on voit
que l'allemagne est pas le meilleur ami
de la russie c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire sur le plan de la géopolitique se
montre assez pragmatique
la france elle semble bloquée pourquoi
mais vous ça fait parce qu'elle est
bloquée elle est empêtrée dans ses
pièges idéologique dont je vous parlais
et l'allemagne un moment angela merkel
ce n'est pas là la qui vaincus n'est pas
requis n'est pas d'une amie de logique
vous le vous le savez bien
concernant le ramenant leur assemblée
nationale cependant quand il s'agit d'un
moment de prioriser l'intérêt général le
son pays par rapport aux intérêts
particuliers par rapport au petit
orgueil et de logique des uns des autres
eh bien madame merkel sait prendre la
bonne décision elle l'a fait
rappelez-vous dans la régulation des
frontières elle a décidé contre vents et
marées contre les décisions de l'ue
européenne quelquefois est bien de
réguler ses frontières pour éviter la
propagation trop forte du virus du coc
vide elle le fait et elle annoncé si une
homologation de l'union européenne
tarder je mettre à disposition de
production et je produirai spoutnik 2 eh
bien elle le fait parce qu'elle défend
et elle souhaite protéger le peuple
allemand
c'est ce que ne fait pas aimé le
maquereau c'est absolument inquiétant et
sexuellement honteux parce que l'union
européenne est très mauvaise l'autre ms
ce matin a déclaré que la la la la
stratégie de vaccination en europe
étaient très lentes
elle était inacceptable bien oui parce
que hossein nurock non seulement nous
sommes mauvais bien sûr mais en plus au
sein de l'europe elle parmi les mauvais
il ya des très mauvais ce sont les
français
nous sommes 11e sur l'injection en un
thème de rang 1 dans les pays européens
en termes d'injection de la première
dose nous sommes 23e je dis bien 23e sur
27 et jeu je m'engage des
téléspectateurs allaient regarder
coville tracker qui vous donnera ses
chiffres la 23e sur 27 sur la deuxième
dose devant nous beaucoup de pays
européens l'espagne l'italie l'allemagne
la hongrie bien événement est hors de
l'union européenne la grande bretagne
les états unis le chili tout le monde
est de même le maroc est à 23 % de sa
population vaccinée parce que ils ont
pris des décisions le spoutnik et au
maroc
le souhait tic et fabriqué produits en
ânes et les diffuser il est en afrique
voilà il ya des gens qui prennent
décision parce qu'ils choisissent le
pragmatisme à l'idéologie ne savons pas
le faire et nous mourons de cela de la
manière
mon père mais j'en avais capelle que
d'ici la fin de l'été tous les français
seront vaccinés qu'on va même devenir en
europe le premier fournisseur au monde
vous y croyez quand même et cet
optimisme
enfin on a d'ailleurs intérêt à ce que
ça soit vrai tout de même bien écoutez
bien avant que je le souhaite mais avec
intérêt le lac rond et est en campagne
présidentielle il avait dit et c'est un
argument de campagne de la part de son
équipe avec marine le pen vous aurez
chaos ni écouter le cas où on l'a avec
emmanuel macron bien sûr mais moi je
souhaiterais bien sûr que que nous
puissions vacciner tout le monde en fait
tous ceux qui le souhaitent le plus vite
possible et je souhaite que les
objectifs qu'il fixe
il a rabaissé il a révisé à la baisse
plusieurs fois je souhaite qu'il soit
atteint mais que de temps perdu
que de temps perdu il disait il ya dans
son allocution rappelez vous lisez le
vaccin a permis de sauver des vies
notamment beaucoup moins de morts
aujourd'hui sur la tranche des plus âgés
il l'a dit textuellement et bien donc à
ce moment-là si si le les signes qu'il
est responsable de devis qui l'a sauvé
il est aussi responsable de vie qui n'a
pas sauvé parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui n'ont pas été vaccinés et qui
aujourd'hui ne sont plus là
malheureusement bien écoutez je souhaite
maintenant bien sûr comme ces objectifs
soient atteints
mais je doute je doute je doute vraiment
qu'il le soit quand je vois que cette
union européenne a très mal négocié de
manière commerciale très mal négocier
ses contrats avec les laboratoires
canapa outil de production qui n'a pas
de souveraineté et d'indépendance
industriel c'est ce qui pose de
problèmes qu'elle a abandonné également
la recherche
il fait que nous sommes quand même un
peu la risée du monde la france sixième
puissance industrielle est la seule à ne
pas avoir de vaccins dans les grandes
puissances mondiales
tout ceci est bien honteux j'espère
qu'on a tiré des leçons mais ça fait
trois ans et demi qui mêle macro nous
dit j'ai compris j'ai compris nous
allons tirer de leçon et nous allons
améliorer les choses
il se passera rien les lits de
réanimation il ya un an promis 1 aura
douze mille rien vous avez dit également
nous allons relocaliser des usines
sanofi avait promis la réalisation du
sinn il ne s'est rien passé depuis
croyez moi je suis bien triste mais ça
n'est pas comme ça qu'on défend son
peuple et son pays
j'en arrive à cappelle députés européens
aux 600 demandes nationales d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt francs